and he's a good guy but yeah to her life
is is crazy
so that kind of sizzled out after a
while how long did that take before it
kind of just you started hearing things
or he was honest with you how does that
work there were things in our marriage
that had happened uh throughout our six
years of being married married together
um and you know you work through them i
know i never got married to get divorced
so it was always something that like you
know we just worked through
and um and then you know tour just uh
accentuated those problems and made
everything that we always kind of fought
and dealt with even worse and um
and it's okay now you know you you look
at things retrospectively and it was
honestly the best thing that ever
happened to me getting a divorce and
going our separate ways we got married
very young and i think that
you know we found out that we actually
weren't the perfect person for each
other and that's okay you know it was a
very very hard awful thing to go through
i'm not trying to put it lightly because
it wasn't at all
but now retrospectively i can look back
and be like you know what
it's all good how do you put things
aside though while you're sitting there
doing a broadway show with woody allen
directing all these big names and you're
it's broadway and all these things are
happening materialize materialize in
front of you how do you
how do you just separate them how do you
go to work and just separate it how do
you do that that's got to be a a mind
sorry for my language first f-bomb
of the day it totally is all day and
then you walk into a theater and you put
makeup on that makes you look like an
accentuated version of yourself and you
put a wig on it makes you feel like
you're not yourself and then you put on
a really cool costume and then you
really don't feel like yourself and then
you're with this whole family that um
you have a extremely close and different
and new relationship with and
then after the show ends you go to the
bar next door and drown your sours
because you don't want to go home and
sit at your house by yourself and so
then you get drunk and then
you repeat the next day and that was my
life that that was how i coped with it
and what was it like working with woody
allen was he just kind of quiet and
distant and just did his job and then
what left and you didn't really get to
talk to him i guess that's how it feels
it'd probably be like yeah yes yes most
of the time and then you had like the
the rare occasions where he would come
over and do cast notes and um
and you know you kind of had to like
pinch yourself that like woody allen's
giving cast notes but he was very quiet
he was he watched
everything all the previews and always
had opinions and things but um yeah he
was he was very quiet he did his own
thing he was always you know his wife
was there and his daughter was there a
lot and um and they were always always
very kind and and but quiet for sure
you